hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to bad dream memories now
there's the fifth part in this series
and it should be just as good as last
ones but because it says memories and
because of the little bit of drawings
that I'm seeing here if probably is
gonna tie together a lot of story and
it's probably gonna be more disturbing
than the other ones but that's good
because we like disturbing here in
markiplier land letters Oh new home dad
me and mom oh this is going to get sad
isn't it oh this is going to get so sad
what how did I do that oh there's going
to be bizarre can I take the teddy bear
okay yeah alright is there something
else that I need to click here am I
missing something
what's going on why can't I get oh I
could get out of this I didn't mean to
do that okay alright okay spider spider
I made you go down a little bit why did
I do that what are you doing what you
what you what do you do what are you
waiting what are you doing what are you
doing huh well you think okay are anyway
moving on okay so this is obviously the
new home that we had together and it
looks so good and I'm so happy for this
family and I know that everything's
gonna go great and these flower people
are dead and it's totally normal and
this outhouse
has a heart on if you know what okay
it's locked
spike Gardein okay she snipped the
flowers with those and for some reason
the kid had a bottle of booze this
doesn't make any sense at all they're
real now oh that's crazy
oh hi
it's that normal just posed to be normal
Oh mind me oh the dad has bottle of
booze oh oh no I thought the dad was
gonna have voila booze is kid gonna have
bottle of booze his mommy I'll have a
bottle of booze how's it going are you
doing oh hey that's not creepy at all
slightly dark picture here okay oh okay
yeah everything is as it should be
is this really a dreamer am I just
coming back into a really weird weird
place
okay so there's really nothing I can do
in this one I thought there would have
been okay but either way I got something
else but I don't know what else to do
with it okay I'll uh I'll be back okay
all right cool
whatever that's fine I guess oh hey I
didn't notice you there
oh you such a good whatever you are can
I have that can I have that you're not
gonna give that to me why aren't you
gonna give that to me please dear God
give that to me give it to me I've worn
it a screw you ha I did okay I got it
okay cool oh oh oh okay that's fine I
guess
it looked really creepy with her in the
window like that and the hammer over
Spike's head I don't like that okay so
oh oh
Spike's house oh
[Music]
oh this is so clever and cool oh it's so
cool oh the fish is dead okay
you spiky one a dead fish me boy Mikey
boy okay I just prayed for it pass
what does that mean pass pass what oh I
have a pastor okay
oh no spike oh oh the whole sky is sad
at spike oh oh good I got a mystery box
I sure do want this to exist in real
life
hi
okay bye cool well I haven't told you
[Music]
okay so now that I have this fakie box
oh oh the Grim Reaper is indisposed at
the moment then I should be able to
place it no I have this can I take this
away from death No
okay so what am I supposed to do now I
don't see a place where I can put Owens
in spikes oh hi are you following me
please don't but so maybe maybe maybe
dammit oh I haven't been back here okay
oh that's a happy thing
oh how to save my parents create tore
toy army to stop death ah that's not all
boxers bringing a scissors Oh Oh No is
this how it all ties together I'm gas
than the other games oh no oh oh oh
first game oh cool congratulations is
that real is that really your first game
that's awesome developer at the end
that's really cool oh man okay there's a
spring okay so I got to find the
scissors again wherever they went
okay's but I got a key and I can use the
key on the outhouse no that was wrong
I'm stupid for thinking that so I need
to son I need to find some way to make
this box real because I haven't been
able to do it in all these other ones so
it's got to be something here that I can
do this too let's go to me oh oh oh here
yes
yeah dear Santa I would like for
Christmas business this and a toy box
yes exactly so underneath the Christmas
tree is gonna be a present okay so I got
that and I can sell all this up so who
death is in the outhouse right now des
is susceptible to my trap yeah
knock knock death hahahahaha I got you
so good I got death I chopped off his
ding-dong
right oh wait but wait a minute what you
can't do anything to stop me I'm sorry
love D oh that's the end oh oh come on
oh you can't leave it like that
why was everything flipper first Oh is
there like something else do this I feel
like I missed something
Oh ah damn it
ah man damn it damn it damn it I want to
know more okay be the way this one's
really good like ah man it was so
intricate and interesting like with that
game mechanic like the idea of like
taking things out of memory and putting
them into memory to make him real to
whatever dream world I was in that was
really clever but I feel like I missed
something
ah okay this is either way there's only
one more game in this series I don't
play it right now because I can't stop
so thank you everybody so much for
watching I really hope you're enjoying
this as much as I am because I am having
a blast and my hair is not cooperating
with me but that's okay because you guys
don't mind red I need hair cut so thank
you everybody know much for watching and
as always I will see you
miss goody goo is gonna do to me forever